un des projets de loi qui pose problème
pour montréal qui est dans la machine on
sait pas s'il sera adopté ou pas c'est
celui qui définit le rôle de
l'inspecteur général le fameux
inspecteur général de denis coderre or
là il ya une petite bataille monsieur
coderre voudrait avoir sur l'inspecteur
général avant le déclenchement des
élections au françois - effectivement et
le gouvernement marois était très claire
aujourd'hui l'inspecteur général le
projet de loi ne fait pas partie des
priorités prioritaires rappelons-le est
comme ça dans les projets de loi adoptés
en outillant temps limite on va miser
sur d'autres projets doit d'abord
monsieur coderre lui en réaction
aujourd'hui dit qu'il voit ce qui se
passe à québec comme étant un jeu de
pouvoir entre les leaders parlementaires
mais il nous dit que lui et son bureau
ont fait une ronde d'apple encore
aujourd'hui parler à philippe couillard
parle aux ministres stéphane bédard et
qu'il a bon espoir que ce projet de loi
là soient acceptées soit adopté avant la
levée de la session finalement avant les
prochaines élections il est très
confiant je vous laisse entendre
monsieur koné
si on veut vraiment aider montréal je
demande à tous les partis politiques de
peau nous mettre entre la baie les
corses ce projet de loi 73 on est tous
ceux pour l'intégrité pour la lutte
contre la corruption alors ils ont une
occasion en or de le faire rapidement un
tiens vaut mieux que deux tu l'auras et
c'est intéressant aujourd'hui d'entendre
monsieur gaudreault le ministre des
affaires municipales dire que monsieur
coderre n'avait pas à dicter l'agenda
politique à québec par contre les maires
eux promettent d'être présent dans la
prochaine campagne électorale il faut
faire des points de presse pendant la
campagne pour inciter les partis
politiques à se prononcer sur terre
certains sujets d'ailleurs ça commence
dès demain les maires forêt labeaume et
coderre en point de presse à québec sur
les régimes de retraite et messieurs la
bombe mais coderre ne nous ont pas
habitués à la discrétion on va
certainement les réentendre au cours de
cette campagne électorale québécoise
merci françois avoir pas de récents
voire